I am a gamer and I do play to win
the Mario Kart on the Rainbow Road scene
yeah I think it's gonna blow some
people's minds because it's uh just as
exciting and fun as like when you're
playing that game what's your winning
strategy now I need to ask you this Jack
because for real we've had an
opportunity to play some Mario Kart
together I do how do you do it how do
you how do you do it kick so much it's a
Mario Kart you know I am a gamer and I
do play to win no one can stop me
Mario Kart if you're in the lead which I
often am you're a Target someone's gonna
zap you someone's gonna splot you what
you want to do is kind of like
Serpentine you want to be a moving
Target and hopefully they'll miss it to
the left and to the right that's one of
my key bits of advice that is that's
actionable advice right there thank you
I wish I'd known that earlier yeah yeah
I was always trying
I need to straighten this card up
whenever you are driving down the road
and you want to yell at someone in
traffic that's your Bowser coming out
the last time I played it I got this
power up that looked like a big giant
you turn into a jet entire jet engine
yes so fast
to have like a super duper power that
you can use at the last second because I
lost a lot of games in the left like I'm
winning I'm winning when I lost because
I didn't you know someone hit me with a
super another great strategy bro this
whole set was orchestrated just to
extract from you this information I
believe you I can't believe you gave it